okay cowboy what's your favorite moment
from this season
i like uh when uh i turned around and it
was
pete and rose standing back there that i
hadn't seen
yeah for all i knew the guy was in
prison or dead or something like i
hadn't seen him in that like
25 years you know yeah and and i didn't
even recognize him i mean
i like it no we're aware we're we are
aware that you didn't recognize that
right yeah i mean that's not pete peter
had about when i knew him he wore like
the mobetta he had like a garth hat like
and then now he's now he's pete like
that pete
i didn't recognize him get over it oh my
god that was happening one of these days
and i can't wait
my favorite moment was turning around
and realizing he was supposed to know me
i mean i get it you don't see each other
for a long time but it was pretty funny
i really liked pete and i was trying to
get him to join my team out of spite
you know he wasn't doing it no no no no
there's something it's the gravitational
pull it's annoying yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever